Hey, Vsauce. Michael here. And I am now living
in London. Besides popping on over to Disneyland
Paris, I've also been looking at DONGs: Things
you can Do Online Now, Guys. For instance,
because I'm now in Britain, my team has changed
for clickclickclick.com. The site recognizes
what country you're in and then asks you
to click as many times as you can. Earn turbo-clicks
to get two minutes of auto-clicking and when
you're done, submit to support your country.
These were the standings when I played.
This website takes a look at your physical
and moral strength and then calculates approximately
how many 5-year-olds you could take in a fight.
Gorillablackdog recommended Drinkify. Tell
it a musician and it will give you some tunes
and a drink recommendation. Now, we all love
soundboards, but when it comes to a button
that makes noises - 10, 100, 1,000 - it's never
enough. Luckily, MyInstants contains literally
more than 3,000 sound clips available with a click.
IFlores105 showed my MyWorldMapper, which
is amazing, it's full of maps of the world
where regions are physically bloated or shriveled,
based on statistics. This one, for instance,
allows you to visually compare how many people
live in cities on Earth.
Themediversion's Image Mosaic Generator is
nice. Upload any image you want and it will
spit you back thousands of images which, from
afar, are your original.
Whoops, are you trying to break the law?
Well, don't do anything until you check out the
Ransom Note Generator. This way, your messages
will be anonymous and needlessly frightening.
If you're like PumpkinHead5150 and you want
to waste time playing free games but also
read some great literature, play Silent Conversation.
Here, you are the "I" floating above text.
Touch every word while maneuvering around
dangerous words.
Aether is an art game where you travel by
using your tongue like a grappling hook. As
you ascend away from a planet, gravity changes,
and you swing through space, fall to other
worlds, and figure out their puzzles.
Once you do, the planet regains its color.
In Prior, you're a square who has forgotten
everything - who you are, who your family is.
All you can hope to do is read scraps of paper
about you to learn your story and how to
even play the game.
Concerned Joe is like being the bus from Speed.
If you don't move, your health falls and
the narrator, well, he's ridiculous. Concerned
Joe was submitted by SporkMurderer. Now, she
might murder sporks, but the internet loves
them, according to WhatDoesTheInternetThink.net.
The site searches a word or phrase you enter
and evaluates the positivity, or negativity,
of what's being said about it on the web.
And look, sporks tend to be discussed with
quite a bit of mirth.
Super Pig. Angelperson0 submitted this.
A game of dark rooms where bacon won't help,
but stumbling onto spikes means that your
blood fluorescently splatters, giving the
next pig an idea of what's ahead. You've only
got so many pigs, so be careful.
Now, if you'd rather splatter something more
humane, be like PryoStar and use JacksonPollock.org.
Every time you click, the color changes. Not
cute enough? Well, Purrgirl234 says Cornify.
Drag this little thing right hear to your
bookmarks bar and BAM. Now, whenever you're
on a site, you can click it to add unicorns.
And here's a game that's like an almost never-ending
brick breaker, except the colored pieces you
break off become balls you can keep using.
Now, ChocolateMilkMonster served us up a Puzzler.
You want all the balls to be the same color
and when you click one it turns a quarter-turn
clockwise, and if its blue lines meet any
of those of balls around it, that ball will
become the same color and also turn a quarter-turn.
Set off small chain reactions and play the
end carefully. Voilá. But in case of emergency,
call the EmergencyYodel.com.
Finally, Reddit user iamcogita created this
YouTube educational mural, it's incredible.
So many of my friends! You can click their
heads to see their channels, or, go straight
to youtube.com/edu to find others like us,
especially the ones who don't appear on camera,
who probably made themselves harder to draw.
Stay saucy.
And as always,
thanks for watching.